la tristesse des hobbies de tir in situ
le gars salaire tu as envie de te
propose un peu plus dans l'action
[Musique]
caroline ithurbide quel âge a votre site
et vais également alors vous avez fait
de s en communication ouais ouais sympa
et laboeuf dirige vraiment qu'elle en
entretien et le saman guava je vous le
dis et alors vous aimez vos billes yoga
boxe thaï gymnastique niveau compétition
brême plastique fait quoi badens c'était
un truc c'était quand j'étais plus jeune
les hommes et genest et poutres tout
[ __ ] et
jean michel maire il a entendu le bo
poutre on dirait qu'on appelait la baffe
à la paix j'ai peine à [ __ ] et avec
l'alphabet s'élever le gars il a levé la
dresser les oreilles
allez jean michel maire tient
jean-michel berre alors il a obtenu un
bac b pour les autres il a eu service
militaire vous avez fait votre service
en 1980 vous étiez avec georges
clemenceau clemenceau de commerce vous
avez fait une maîtrise en communication
et journalisme et ouais après
journalistes à l'est républicain fait
l'hiver oui ah ouais ouais
grégory super à la flandre à quoi faire
et grégory que c'est un grand reporter à
france soir chef sur un service chef du
service radio télévision figaro jusqu'en
2010 et chroniqueur et ensuite vous êtes
chamois d'heure
ce n'est pas parce que l'hiver c'est
l'hiver ce brevet de pilote chamois d'or
c'est le fromage skins qui d'accord
brevet de secouriste qui donne trois
séries hbo tient marié 51 ans
oui j'ai dit 54 ans vous donne les
agents
merci obtention d'un bac à un pareil
c'était elle a maintenant ma de philo
way a duré très longtemps
ça n'existe plus et alors je vous dire
hey les mecs la tristesse des hobbies
qua non la tristesse des hobbies de
tirer en tutu
le gas alberta envie de proposer à nos
bureaux les
tu es assez mais normalement c'est un
candidat des sunnites et des lettres
cassées mise en place à l'est j'ai perdu
50 est alors aussi
ouais c'est gentil ça derrière un set de
table
trouvez pas ça bon c'est dégueulasse
j'ai eu tous les compliments g caroline
et moi même j'ai même choisi avec
mathieu rouy bye bye c'est bien foutu de
données comme ça jusqu'au mont va bien
boutonnée jusqu'au vous êtes bien
dégueulasse comme if you know 83 il a
été finaliste de mister camping sauvage
[Rires]
finaliste qu'à innover c'est pas une
formation en mai que souza effet j'ai
été battu de justesse
bah oui oui avec du camping sauvage et
on était une bonne quinzaine comme ça il
ya eu un vote et j'ai perdu je m'en veux
encore
j'aurais dû gagner ah oui très bien très
bien vous êtes alors est quand même il a
été journaliste et rédacteur en chef du
parisien journaliste l'équipe
chroniqueur radio directeur adjoint de
la rédaction de france soir
professeur de journalisme à l'oeil j
paris et chroniqueur à chaque fois c'est
ça fait marrer alors question mais vie
fatou bâ et mélanie la télévision c'est
légal los angeles londres et du ton et
de reggae tout à shakespeare le football
le ski de fond l'amour la marche rapide
le cinéma à la séance de 9 heures aux
halles
[Applaudissements]
et rapide et gilles verdez co vous
faites la marche rapide ah oui c'est ma
spécialité des mecs qui m'a
c'est max mara je suis à une souris dans
les halls slip fait un peu un beau
déhanché m amène un abonné au chili
[Rires]
[Musique]